[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
we talk about whatever we won't and we
got just in the hot seat yeah we got two
couples on either side of us these are
hot seats - oh it's true we're not
married today that's why we're fighting
but that's what they think
don't worry wait Steve doesn't wear ring
Nicky doesn't wear her brain okay
fighting who's actually fighting in
their relationship right now
anybody y'all really know I think fights
always so funny I thought I'd be cool
Todd busselton fights are not me the
fight itself are never funny but then
when you think about it later and how
it's affecting moms like oh my god I
can't believe we have a father a long
time
then what's the funny fight I can think
of when you guys shared the one where
you guys were fighting in the beautiful
wilderness and seven years old yeah we
talked about that one that one this
issue fighting in a screen saver during
the [ __ ] thing he was the only one I
laughing I'm like you're lame I got
nothing to fight with her about because
she has been the [ __ ] champion
for me the past I have you been a
champion for her Steve Vockrodt
I haven't gotten no dick physically do
it but if he's out of your feet that she
wants the dick oh she wants the dick
just wanted to talk about it but you
know she wants to do that really you
don't want to just like get you know it
hasn't been offered on the table it
wasn't like off the table it was just
never ever on the table well I had I had
these are this is like the first day
that I haven't had crazy like bouts of
what I've been dealing with so what have
you been dealing with why are you
keeping it behind us right so yeah I had
kidney stones for the past months now I
haven't for basically a month yeah did
you get surgically removed yeah I got to
get them surgically removed
Niki's channels see the vlog it was a
centimeter big yeah is it a big guy god
yeah so unfortunately it happened what
we're in Costa Rica you can check out
the vlog I think his channel she kills
into it like really well but the main
thing is I really honestly thought that
I was gonna die cuz I didn't know what
was happening to me like I thought I was
gonna die too because he's never acted
this way I've never seen him even show
the slightest bit of pain ever and he
couldn't move it was not you've never
felt this pain before I think you said
before but it wasn't as a different pain
it was AA kidney stones before I had ten
years ago it's not common that should
have been your turn your challenge I
didn't catch that one one of the
funniest things that happened during the
whole thing was as I was going in for
surgery I'd never had surgery before but
I'm sitting in there and I'm in a
roomful like I don't know there's
probably seven people in there cuz all
separated by partition well we all
[ __ ] 80 years old you're the only one
oh ah it was it was quite like average
age is like 45 or 50 but everyone had a
rockstar t-shirt on though yeah net to
rock star that hat the parking lot was
filled monster energy no so so this guy
in the couple curtains over from me he
he out loud he's like he's like oh man
I'm so [ __ ] scared damn dude you
can't take it like a man like he was not
taking them like a man at all he was uh
he was very afraid and he was wait wait
but that'sthat's toxic man it's okay I
know it's toxic masculinity okay for you
to feel pain and be scared no but take
it like a man is like you could be
scared and all these all these things
but you're not being a little [ __ ]
about it and this guy was being like a
man [ __ ] about it like a full-on
clucking chicken about it and it was it
was funny because I was nervous but then
this is made me kind of laugh like
sitting there cuz he was just such a
coward about it it makes you feel better
don't it the best was when he asked the
nurse yeah yeah
so then he asked the nurse the nurse is
like you know she's like how can I help
you sir and he's like he's like have you
ever been on the side of it before you
ever been sitting Ronson and she's like
yeah I have actually a couple times it
was great it was this little gift to me
coz it was it was like perfect it was
like if you're writing a movie that's
what you write for them to say to
heighten it for the character who's
about to go in themselves I love how the
lady has bike experience there yeah
exactly she was just throwing away like
yeah a couple times telling you the
hospital sponsored by monster dude it
was a lot man and then coming out of
surgery was pretty crazy cuz I collect
and I go into the bathroom well first to
give me like a bedpan thing to use the
bathroom and then I had to keep going is
that like it's pretty weird yeah but at
least I'm a dude so you just stick your
dick in the bottle and you're good like
I can't imagine being a chick and trying
to figure that out
yeah whatever they give you this like a
receptacle with a little thing on there
going in there they'd already gone in
there and they and they had already put
in the stent so it was attached with
string hanging out of my damn who's fun
so so then yeah I couldn't use the
bathroom easily so but when I go in
there having never seen it before cuz I
just went I just dip the thing under to
go to use it and then I hand it to the
lady and I noticed it was all red yeah
and then so that I can have a dick and I
ever hurts me it was crazy right so then
I go in the bathroom and it was whit
it's like they shoved the Phillips head
screwdriver up my dick because it was
like sprinkling all over like a [ __ ]
horror movie like [ __ ] blade when the
vampires like all the [ __ ] [ __ ] comes
out of the sprinkler the blood shower
yeah dude it was like that [ __ ] huh
when I I tried to clean it up with [ __ ]
but I was just in so much pain like my I
was like shaking and pain and [ __ ] and
like my legs were shaking and I was
trying to bend over and like sweet the
Queen machinery aren't any painkillers
at this point no nothing well I was
coming off of anesthesia
yeah so so then um I walked out of there
and it looked like I just had a baby on
the ground you don't feel like it was
crazy and I looked at the nurse lady and
I went yeah it was intense man hey those
are a couple moments of fun of levity
for me were you able to catch up with
the guy that was next door that was
screaming no I don't even think yeah he
made it actually he passed away
Yeah right poor guy poor bastard he was
actually right you know in his gut
was pretty pretty dead on no I have no
idea yeah I've never had surgery before
that's kind of scary yeah weird like
it's a good time as they put you under
and you just get the chill out and they
do their own thing
it's pretty [ __ ] fun they took outs I
had three front hear about that and you
know this and your guitar my friend so
adorable yeah so the no I did not I
knocked out woke up cool and then the
second time was for my knee surgery
same [ __ ] tore meniscus yep and then it
was my titties and then I woke up I was
like I woke up in the first thing I told
in here so I'm like oh did she go like
gonna happen a lot when you were getting
wheeled in for surgery did you do you
have people walking down the hall by you
and looking at you as you're getting
wheeled in no it was just what I had a
private room and then from my room and
just what's the surgery did you ever go
go into the like were you able to stay
conscious enough to get into the or yeah
like on the table every single time my
appendix no cuz he wanted to show me
everything so I got to see it every
single time I did that I was on the
table they just told me the procedure
and then they um they're the
anesthesiologist guy come in and then
he's like cool cuz he was talking to me
about cold for the playoffs and you know
we
that's fine but we're talking about that
a little bit yeah so then then he gives
it to me and then they're wheeling me
down the hallway and everybody that I
saw like like I'm the guy in bed you
know what I mean and so everybody that I
saw they're all looking at me and I'm
thinking like oh I'm the guy right now
like everyone's looking at me like oh I
wouldn't want to trade places with that
guy you know I'm like every person is
look at me they're all looks like yeah
like that [ __ ] that's [ __ ] Frankie
weird thing right yeah and then that's
like the last thing that I remember is
all these people looking at me like oh I
wouldn't trade places with that yeah and
then and then I see the doors and then
I'm I wake up oh [ __ ] I didn't see it
was just like from my room and then I'd
lay me down and I'm just chilling and
then that's it and then when I wake up
I'm back in my room yeah it feels like
when you're watching a video or a movie
or whatever and there's a cutting you're
somewhere else that's what it feels like
that's gotta be so bad I wasn't a
different room like I didn't wake up in
the same room I only got one surgery was
like to get my wisdom teeth removed
because they were impacted and like they
had me count backwards from 10 in that
room and then I don't remember making it
to the one and then I woke up in a
different room and I was so confused
about where I was and it was like that
were they edited to like cut to and
you're in a different room you're like
that's exactly if you get choked out or
knocked out you oh really
yeah like you just like black guard or
whatever and like let's say you surgery
kinda [ __ ] you like you're like your
faces on the floor the world is sideways
and then your memory comes back to you
kind of like in reverse order so you're
like wait okay wait when I'm on the
floor
wait this grounds kind of sticky and
then they're like oh wait I was just
like grappling with someone oh and then
that's the I remember I was grappling
with oh it has arms around my neck yeah
I got here earlier and it's like kind of
like slowly comes back to you it's like
all I lost here on the floor waking up
no but that's why it takes time we're
like when they get when they get back up
- like did I win - like no you love
don't know what's happening right now I
do like I heard I heard that's what
happened Rama Rao see cuz she got
knocked out yeah and then she woke up
and she's like they're like hey you know
we want to get you ready for your next
you have C fight and she's like you see
I'm in the WWE right well she didn't
even know and that's why I heard it
happened
see I think Geo has the best story
because it's like you wake up and now
you have chitti's that's pretty good oh
yeah I was a [ __ ] it was off that's
you should have wrote that review on
Yelp for them when asleep and then I
woke up with tits yeah I've never gotten
any like cosmetic surgery before I like
nothing I'm against that I think I would
want to at some point but but like so I
say I think all of red light me here all
right you know I think you're beautiful
thank you what I'm so beautiful and I
want to look just like you and your tits
are amazing and okay go ahead and you
ever naturally flat something unlike me
I want to get it take it anyway yeah I
just thought it was interesting cuz I'm
there's a girl that I follow that I'm
friends with that was like kind of
talking about how almost all of her
friends in LA have gotten some sort of
procedure done and how no one talks
about it and like she was just becoming
more transparent about all the
procedures she's had done and I had no
idea that it was like Botox is like
crazy
yeah and lip plumpers and then a New
Year's someone asked me if I Botox and I
was like no like to me I had always
grown up thinking like oh when you're
older then maybe you do Botox or a
facelift or whatever but that was
shocked like a bunch of young people I
know people in their 20s still do Botox
and I was like why you don't have
wrinkles and like oh it's to prevent
wrinkles yeah really
yeah how'd you get them in afterwards
from Botox once it wears off no no
yeah like it prevents you because then
it like basically prevents you from
making facial expression it stretches it
out so much that what the starts wearing
off like the stretch effect coming I
wish is that Bart's Plastic Surgeons
marching music he [ __ ] nobody's like
it getting Botox every [ __ ] every time
you know you said looks like what's
Botox again yeah that you you cheeky
[ __ ] you were supposed to see you
were supposed to air out his dirty
laundry him boys still lost
Botox translates to something scary like
poison or parallelization or something
like that yeah but it's so like it's
such a small amount but they use Botox
to treat migraines but you have to get
it all in your head Oh see you like a
hundred [ __ ] shots or some why it's a
scary amount does anyone ever like hey
while you're in there yeah I do some
more and then lip fillers to do like I
was I was like wow everyone has such
nice lips and then doing they're all
fillers like yeah and then my one friend
that's lived here all her life like
lived in LA Hollywood she used to work
at a plastic sort of facial surgeons
office a cosmetic surgery I don't know
what's called but like just for the face
and she could tell like each person
she's like she's had cheek fillers she's
got her job
like she could list each one and I was
like wow they I wouldn't have never
guessed
I think lip fillers from what I've seen
maybe they're bad jobs I always think
they look so funny oh the duck lips ones
they look like they got punched in the
mouth those are the bad ones I think
about it like this you only would notice
the bad ones yeah how would you notice
the good ones like that's a good family
you only noticed about it I want to see
the good ones to see how good I'll show
you a bunch of Instagram pages some
natural one good ones but it's only like
in the last two years the injectors are
just now starting any game when they
don't go too crazy on the top when it's
like a little bit on the bottom and then
like teeny tiny bit on the top because
the top lip is the one that looks the
craziest what they have to do I think
what they didn't figure out for the
longest time is that you have to do like
a little bit wait a couple weeks do a
little bit waiting for the week like
because they used to just inject like
the whole [ __ ] thing at once and then
it looks all crazy do you see that one
girl that was on like she went viral
because she had that was funny I like
that we were the Kylie lip challenge
thing the kids were all do their mouths
well Bruce you know that YouTube is
gonna start crying cracking down on
those challenges and challenges well my
art breadbox challenge katsu Montez
that's a big one Jones did too but
what's silly is that like the
blindfolded challenge was already a
thing they just renamed it the burr box
challenge but now it's demonic it's
because of the Tide Pods like anything
with those names in the title they're
all good at anything what the challenge
is getting tomorrow even if it's not
dangerous cuz Joe and the deme sat down
and try to figure out what flavor
skittles they were with a blind girl we
just painted our nails and stuff you too
doesn't those too many people are doing
dumb [ __ ] that's why yeah but they're
not banding people eat and [ __ ] slime
and shit-eating slime
just get title it slime challenge yeah
go do the JK news Factor where you just
title it something see we can't do
punishments anymore on JK party I'll get
to monetize cuz you know it's dangerous
c-section Casey because we just uploaded
a video today and I'm like I'll remove
the regeneration
because it was about Casey's parents or
in Hong Kong and then Casey's parents
sound like a whole bunch of old photos
from when they were young so then we
titled it like parents do a 40 year
challenge I think challenge is okay I
think it's just dangerous challenge
dangerous challenge ones that we have
gone viral that YouTube has been noted
but then it could be something so like
when we were planning our wedding in
France and it was during the same time
where something happened in France it
was like bombing oh yeah just by us
having France
it would demonetised like it'd be
flagged like yeah and you don't even
want to take the risk of like it being
demonetised for a few like a few hours
and then you think I'm coming back
you're still gonna you make all your
money like the first 48 72 hours or
whatever so by the time the pie figures
out
oh this isn't actually a real like
really stupid things you don't need lost
all your money yeah but I love how you
do bake don't worry we got it all
cleared up for you and it's been like
nine days yeah we're gonna make like $8
of that yeah they didn't do monetize
until after like two days so hopefully
yeah yeah for the majority of it it was
like okay we've made our money back I
mean I paid an editor so basically like
even doubt yeah
did you just have like a program where
you get to submit the video a week
before you want to publish it yeah I'll
just screen it and now you know it's
like fail proof wouldn't that be tight
or to be whitelisted and then if you
[ __ ] up and you're off the list you're
not equal to you at least like you're
honest list that's right we trust you I
thought they did this maybe I'm making
this up but while it's getting reviewed
like the money that it's making it
should still make it but they hold it
everyone's an ideal me oh but okay well
they should do something like that so
they can still guys this make sense they
can put it to the side and then it's
greenlit then it just goes yeah but then
if it's not real it then YouTube gets to
keep all that out exactly they get to
keep oh you want to keep it right but
there's more incentive for them not to
let you give it to you
that yellow sign made money off of your
video but you didn't even get to keep it
all right good job that's why I don't
make these rules
[Music]